I've written an email every single day
for my business for the last three
years. That's over a thousand emails.
And every day I use this exact same
structure. I call it the SLO, the slow
structure. So what it starts is it
starts with a story that pivots to a
lesson that connects to an offer. So 80%
of your email should be a story. And the
reason it should be a story is because
you're not only buying the click for
today with your email, but you're
building a relationship so that whenever
you send an email tomorrow and the next
day or whenever in the future, people
were entertained
by your email prior that they're going
to say, "Oh, I'd love to click that."
Right? You want to entertain more than
you give information because information
is dry. It's dull. It's not exciting.
People don't want to access that when
they could just go to chatbt and Gemini
and all these things to read more dense
information. They want to be
entertained. You are competing with
Netflix and Tik Tok and platforms like
that that are keeping their attention,
getting that dopamine hit. You want to
be the dopamine hit. But from there, you
can't just be the dopamine hit. Then you
have to extract one tiny lesson from
that dopamine hit because people don't
want to just get the nasty Tik Tok vibe
after they read your content, right?
They get off Tik Tok and they're like,
"Oh, gross. I should have done something
productive with my life." Right? You
want to get that lesson in there where
you did entertainment, but you give kind
of like a moral of the story where it's
like, "And this is why." And you get
that and you're like, "Oh." Oh, and so
they get the entertainment, they enjoy
your content, but then they learn
something small from it. So that way
they don't feel bad about reading your
content. And then from there, that
lesson, that thing that you taught them
should hit them in the fields like, "Oh
man, I could do that better." Or, "Yeah,
man, that's good to know." And that
thing that hits them in the fields could
be solved with your offer. So whatever
you taught them with their lesson, that
lesson should hit them. And the offer
should solve the problem that you just
hit them with. Like, man, and that's why
you should be emailing every day, right?
And then you say, and if you want to
learn how to email every day, buy my
blah blah blah. Right? And so, you're
telling a story about it, you give them
a lesson that's like, oh, that makes a
lot of sense. And then an offer that can
solve the problem of the lesson. That is
the SL framework.